you say that there are uh very simple
like
ways to citizen like three or four ways
to citizen can you give them to me in a
nutshell so i can then
maybe do one of them but not all three
or four they're conceptual and i i speak
in we
a lot when i talk about this show i say
we thought about this and we my wife
is my like partner in architecting
how we approach the subject oh wait so
you and your wife agree on things
let's talk about that let's switch
chairs
can i talk to you for seven hours you
can absolutely do that we'll make time
um so yeah we wanted to make sure that
we weren't just making stuff up
in candy b's just turn on the microphone
and just tell people things and so it's
like what do we believe
that this word should mean if we
interpret citizen as a verb four things
it means we show up and participate
there's an active thing yep so just show
up
do something get in the game yeah second
it means we recognize that we are
dependent on others
that we need each other so we invest in
relationships with other people
you can't citizen alone i remember when
the u.s had this motto for the army
army of one that didn't make a lot of
sense to me because that's not an
army that's a dude with a gun and also
no one's afraid of an army of one
no that's just oh that's jerry you know
all right you've asked for it we're
sending jerry yeah no one's intimidated
by jerry
so we need other people so let's work on
that and invest in other people and our
relationships
the third is really important is
understanding our power and i think so
much so many times um
our power as citizens gets reduced to
voting it's like you have amazing power
as citizens in a democracy and your your
power
is to give that power to someone else
right every two or four years
and hope they do a good job maybe harass
them by faxing them every now and then
with your demands
we can spend our money in certain ways
we associate with people or not
we share certain ideas or not we gather
physically
in protest or celebration that's all
forms of power so we need to understand
that power that's the third
and the last is we do all this for the
benefit of the many
not just the few and our first guest in
the first season
a brilliant woman named valerie core
wrote this book called see no stranger
and the idea was a stranger is a part of
me i do not yet know
so let me treat everybody as a part of
myself
let me love myself let me love others
let me even love my opponents
and through that act of love not the
sentimental kind but a deeper
civic kind of love right we can move
this whole thing forward
so if everybody is connected if we're
all in this together
then when we do things for the many
socialist leaning things like public
roads or hospitals or education
or healthcare then we're doing it for
ourselves
too i love that that a stranger is the
part of me i don't know
i absolutely love that valerie core said
it yeah yeah yeah yeah
it can be misused if you're getting too
close to someone on a bus
that's what i'm going to use from now on
when we're like hey back off pal
you're the part of me i don't know
um that is fantastic uh thank you so
much for stopping in
seriously this has been fantastic
beautiful it's chill
yeah this is about his i'm highly
medicated um
thank you for being here and classing up
the joint a little bit uh season two
of how to citizen with baratunde is now
available on all
podcast platforms and it's a rare thing
it's a podcast doing some good
something i'm clearly not in favor of
and if folks want to learn more yeah you
can go to the website we have
howtocitizen.com
we're rolling out more features there's
a podcast but we're also
i think we really believe in helping
people through this because i know
from personal experience i wanted to do
more
yeah there's so many people i mean
scientists were marching conan like
people want to do stuff they're so
people are popping up refrigerators to
feed people in their communities
what else can we do so we're asking and
trying to answer that question
with the with the people